[Music]
are there any particular
tools
that you use plants or otherwise for
writing i imagine you still do a fair
amount of writing is there anything that
has filled that gap for you
one is matcha green tea
and the other is coca leaf
and
as you know i'm a great fan of of coca
leaf and i've worked for
many years to try to rehabilitate coca
to teach people the differences between
coca and cocaine
and i'm delighted to see finally after
all this time there is some momentum
building around legalizing coca making
it available
what is that momentum if you could speak
to because i've had very limited
exposure to coca but it was given to me
when i suffered from altitude sickness
in south america and i mean literally
within 45 minutes my symptoms had all
but vanished it was
incredible to
experience the effects
firsthand but what momentum what changes
are you seeing in the united states well
first of all there's a lot of changes in
colombia and in other countries and in
this country too
there are groups forming really working
to legalize coca to make it medically
available to make it available to people
to teach people the differences between
coke and cocaine one group that i've
been doing some work with that you may
know of is the river sticks foundation i
do cody swift as director cody swift and
they're very interested in trying to
fund coca research to document some of
the medical benefits
but it's the first time in in
40 some years that i've seen any change
in attitudes up here and i think would
be a great thing for people to have
access to coca it's it's not cocaine it
has distinct effects it has unique
medical effects
we should have access to it not to
mention the fact that this is the sacred
plant of
a great many indigenous people in south
america and it has been so demonized by
our society and i think given all the
momentum around
looking at indigenous cultures and
rights that this also plays into this of
rehabilitating the sacred leaf
i agree with that 100 i want to give
river six foundation
cody swift and his team also a nod for
their work with respect to an
organization called the indigenous
peyote conservation initiative ipci yeah
great which
purchased a tract of land
in texas so not too far from where i
live although texas is effectively a
country it's gigantic so don't
underestimate drive time
and
it is it has become such a symbol of
hope
for so many
native
american groups throughout the united
states including groups who historically
would not necessarily automatically get
along it's been this unifying
sort of catalyzing project so i want to
give them a nod for that could you speak
to and explain the beneficial plants
research association
well it's a research foundation that i
started in 1979
way ahead of its time
we had a stellar advisory board
including
dick schulte's albert hofmann
alexander shulgin
and i mean it was amazing advisory group
and the purpose of this
was to look at
plants that had been neglected or
unrecognized that could be of great
benefit up here
starting with coca was one of the main
ones but we looked at other kinds of
stimulants
kava which at that time was relatively
unknown
so the idea was to get research going on
these to teach people about them and as
i say it was just way ahead of its time
so eventually
we folded but i'm really interested in
resurrecting this and a common interest
that of cody swift in mind is
looking at at demonized plants
and my feeling has always been you know
a theme of my writing has been that
there are no good or bad drugs there are
just good and bad relationships with
drugs and i think you can broaden that
to plants as well
coca being a prime example we've said
that is a bad plant you know the source
of of all sorts of trouble but the
problem is how we've related to that
plant taking cocaine out of it and
making that available and i think if you
look at there's a whole bunch of other
plants that we consider problematic and
it's really how we've related to them
that's the problem and i think it would
be interesting to try to rehabilitate
some just as an example things like
ephedra
and cot
opium poppies
tobacco even that it's our misuses of
these that have caused trouble it's not
the plan itself
you